are those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
stevie wonder could say that this man
needed medical help
tonight on politics now the case of
byron williams who died in metro police
custody
the family of george floyd and their
attorney join a lawsuit against the
department
plus fiore under the microscope a
potential fbi investigation into the
city councilwoman's finances
every city across the country is
struggling with this response right now
finding affordable housing and shelter
for our homeless population we speak
with las vegas councilman brian knudsen
about how the city plans to address this
issue with federal funding
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler and we start with the
death of byron williams he died in metro
police custody nearly two years ago
video captured williams saying several
times he couldn't breathe during the
arrest
similar to the death of george floyd in
minneapolis last year
now williams attorney and his family
suing metro police
and floyd's family is joining the case
our i-team has followed the case closely
vanessa murphy here with the latest
developments vanessa
john as you mentioned this is a case
which attorneys say
is similar to the murder of george floyd
but for the most part it's gone under
the radar
nationally now some big names in the
civil rights community are stepping in
they're calling out the metro police
department and the clark county district
attorney
byron williams told officers he couldn't
breathe
24 times stevie wonder could see
that this man needed medical help on
thursday
matters civil rights attorneys including
ben crump
the family of byron williams and the
nephew and brother of george floyd
demanded transparency and accountability
you have no choice but to think about
george floyd because the situations are
similar in so many ways
byron williams should not
have been killed by the police
for riding a bicycle while black on
september 5th
2019 metro officers tried stopping
williams for not having a bicycle light
he ran an officer appeared to put a knee
on his back
while williams repeatedly told officers
he couldn't breathe
they did not immediately provide aid or
call for medical attention
they joked williams may just not want to
go to jail
officers turned their body cameras off
and then back on while at the scene
williams was pronounced dead that
morning the clark county coroner ruled
his death a homicide because the prone
restraint
officers kept him in was a factor and
also noted he had methamphetamine in his
system and other health
issues now the family of williams is
suing four
officers at the scene the metro police
department
sheriff joe lombardo clark county and
the city of las vegas
according to a metro spokesman all four
officers named in the lawsuit are
currently working
the clark county district attorney
previously announced
they would not be charged i can't
believe that they're still
wearing that uniform that they still
have a badge
and they're supposed to protect and
serve the community
lawyers are also calling for an
investigation by the department of
justice
and the nevada attorney general we
reached out to aaron ford's office and a
spokeswoman says they cannot confirm or
deny whether they have an
ongoing criminal investigation the legal
team for byron williams family
also claims that metro is not releasing
all of the footage from the scene
a department spokesman tells me that
isn't true and all footage has been
released
in october metro announced policy
changes following william's death
pertaining to use of force
and body cameras as we mentioned this is
a story the i-team has been following
closely
you can watch our previous reports at
8newsnow.com john and what's interesting
vanessa of course
joe lombardo the sheriff is running for
governor i have to imagine this issue
will play a part in the campaign as it
moves forward as well
now earlier in the week you also had a
story about a threat against the
daughter of current governor steve
sisilak
that's right john a woman is charged
with leaving an obscenity-filled tirade
on voicemail for governor
sisilek's daughter we obtained the
arrest report for samaria burton who
faces a misdemeanor charge
the case dates back to november metro
police say burton was
apologetic and admitted to leaving the
voicemail
she said she saw a social media post
from the governor's daughter about
another
possible covet shutdown she was
concerned it could prevent her from
spending time with her family for the
holidays
most of the language in the voicemail we
cannot say on television
the i-team examined the arrest report we
have a closer look
at eightnewsnow.com i also talked with
burton's attorney
you can find that there as well vanessa
thank you very much
also with regards to the governor's
office some changes in his team his
chief of staff and another senior
adviser are moving on
michelle white and scott gillies taking
new jobs
white says that she will stay on as
chief of staff for governor sysolak
until a replacement is found
gillies last day was friday both had
been on the governor's
staff for two years the fbi may be
investigating las vegas city
councilwoman michelle fiore's finances
fellow councilwoman victoria seaman told
the las vegas review journal the fbi
interviewed her over fourth of july
weekend
recently seaman and fiore reportedly had
a falling out
the rj reports seaman did not explain
what finances caught
the fbi's attention however our i-team
has previously reported on complaints
filed with secretary of state's office
about fiore's campaign money going to
her business
or her family members you can watch
those stories as well at 8newsnow.com
fiore is also nevada's gop committee
woman responsible for the party's
fundraising here in nevada
it's a problem local governments like to
have nevada clark county the city of las
vegas they have a whole bunch of federal
economic recovery money
burning a hole in their pocket right now
clark county for example has about 440
million dollars
and has to submit a recovery plan to the
treasury department by the end of august
commissioners have been holding public
meetings to solicit ideas on how to
spend that money on affordable housing
looking at this money is a once in a
lifetime opportunity
to change um generations moving forward
all the money has to be obligated by
december 31st
2024 right the money has to be spent
two years after that now the city of las
vegas is getting 130 million dollars of
that federal money
i sat down with city councilman brian
knudsen to talk about how he thinks the
city should spend it
what is the need in las vegas to address
the issues of
homelessness uh affordable housing
shelter
uh how how much need is there right now
so there's need in all three of those
categories so right now in
southern nevada we're about 50 000 units
short for
for units for people to move into and so
i don't know if if you know this but our
population is going to grow
significantly over the next 25 years
another 500 000 people or so in just the
city of las vegas we'll have
300 000 people in the next 25 years so
that's a lot of people
from a from an everyday person
standpoint from an
individual who's suffering from
homelessness we have 6 000 people who
are unsheltered at this point and so we
have to figure out how we can
provide shelter for them and then create
a system where they can have case
management
have shelter have access to to
clinical appointments for mental health
and potential drug abuse and then we
need to get them into a stable housing
situation
i remember before you're on council you
and i had a discussion about sort of the
gulf between the need and the resources
and the
the effort on a local government
standpoint to try and address this do
you
envision from your point on city council
that there's at least
an effort in some way to address this
there is a
community response i think everyone
every city across the country is
struggling with this
response right now especially with those
struggling with homelessness so
we can't think about it just in terms of
housing although that is a critical need
we have to think about it in terms of
building out the mental health
infrastructure the substance abuse
infrastructure
we have to create space for people to
receive those kinds of
services and then get them into housing
aligned with the housing we have to have
substantial case management to make sure
that they have
the resources they need to stay stay
housed it's always a challenge for
non-profits to get the money they need
it's
it's always kind of a this unspoken dog
fight to make sure that they can get
whether it's grants or or funding from
government entities
what kind of uh maybe fights not the
wrong word but
the um push to try and get some of that
money
will that will the will the resources be
available to help
all of the entities these organizations
in town because the need is so great
there will never be enough resource for
that um what i think we want to focus in
on at the city of las vegas is building
out the infrastructure
so we do not have enough women and
children shelters in our community we do
not have
the medical infrastructure so it's it's
going to be buying land it's going to be
building buildings
so that some of those nonprofit
organizations can come in and
provide services that our community
desperately needs
you're on the council what kind of a
reception is there by others on the
council that maybe not don't have the
same
political uh views that you might have
what kind of a reception is there from
some sort of a unified
response on the council diocese to
approve whoever
wants to get some of this funding i
think across the board whether you're
democrat or republican on the city or
the county or the state
every elected official is getting those
calls asking for support for
those who are struggling with
homelessness and so i think across the
board we all understand the need to
build out housing
we all understand the need to build out
shelter and navigation space and we all
understand the need to build up the the
medical infrastructure
so i don't think you're going to see a
big diversity and thought on that
i think we will have really good
conversations
around which organizations are best to
do it i think we're going to have really
good conversations about
where we want to prioritize if we want
to spend time on
building transitional housing if we want
to spend time on building sheltering
space
if we want to spend time and money
building out the medical infrastructure
i think we're all going to have
diversity of thought there and that's
what makes our city great that's what
makes our county great so it makes the
country great diversity
the city and clark county are taking
public comment on these plans right now
we have links so you can weigh in on
what's going on
at eightnewsnow.com next on politics now
following the money
what's been raised for congressional
races and who's lining up a run for the
senate plus
dealing with drought the several fronts
nevada's working on to try and keep the
colorado river
from sinking further this is 8 news now
tonight on politics now we are following
the money with a key reporting deadline
this week we're going to take a look at
the campaign fundraising
for the second quarter and first as you
see behind me there congresswoman susie
lee in congressional district three
the democrat raised six hundred thousand
dollars and says she has more than nine
hundred twenty five thousand dollars in
cash on hand
four republicans have filed to run
against her april becker who
narrowly lost a state senate race last
year has raised the most money she's
raised 143 thousand dollars and only
spent about 10 grand so far
mark robertson has raised 69 thousand
dollars
up next congressman stephen horsford in
congressional district four he has
raised
about five hundred seventy thousand
dollars he says he has one point two
million dollars on hand right now
republican challenger sam peters has
raised the most from the republican side
spent about twenty thousand dollars of
it so far carolina serrano has also
declared that she plans to run but she
hasn't filed any paperwork yet that
we've found
on the fec website so far the most high
profile race that will be for
senate senator catherine cortez masto up
for re-election
she has raised about 2.8 million dollars
so far
she has more than six million on hand
for the campaign two republicans have
filed to run against her although
neither one of us posted any fundraising
reports just yet
one is nevada 2020 a winner
shirelle mendenhall she owns a talent
agency here in town and describes
herself as a
strong christian and lifelong
conservative second is army veteran
named sam brown he was injured in
afghanistan and released his first ad
already
if you're ready to put others first if
you're ready to take back control and
demand accountability from a political
class
that has failed to serve the
constitution then i hope you'll join our
movement
i'm sam brown and i'm running for u.s
senate
so far they are the only two people to
actually file to run former attorney
general adam laxalt is also testing the
waters
as for the work on capitol hill senator
cortez masto and congresswoman susie lee
they've introduced a bill to try and
deal with the drought on the colorado
river
this new measure opens up federal
funding to address mitigation and water
saving plans
i spoke with the senator about her her
bill
so the legislation that i'm introducing
um and
will be working on as part of the
package tomorrow in enr
energy and natural resources focuses on
large-scale water recycling projects
uh what is that that means you're taking
uh water like sewage water and recycling
it into drinking water
now nevada does a really good job and
already does that but there are several
states along with colorado that do not
so the legislation that i have
incentivizes them to engage in these
large-scale
projects with the benefit of a grant
program through the department of
interior
and the legislation is important
obviously because the more water that we
can
new water that we can really put back
into the colorado
uh helps nevada and so many other states
is there
in your view a willingness on farmers on
other states organizations upstream from
nevada
to want to take advantage of a grant
program like this
absolutely and i that that's the goal
here is listen we are all
the states that border the the colorado
and take water from the colorado of all
the states we all have to work
well together and we do the
collaboration is so
important for us uh particularly
as we all seek the water off the
colorado for
our communities and that that that is a
working relationship
it requires the federal government to
work with us the department of the
interior or overseas or is the
the keeper of the law of the river um
and the bureau of reclamation which is
just as important for the hydropower
that comes
from the colorado river as well so yes
there is a collaboration and we've seen
it in nevada the conservation that can
happen when
community members everybody comes
together to recognize that
really drought is our norm and we have
to plan for that we have to understand
it
and we have to conserve our water and we
have to make sure that we are
conserving it and preserving it for
future as well
now that bill did pass the first hurdle
in capitol hill and made it out of its
first committee
this week we'll keep you posted next on
politics now are changes coming in cuba
we'll have a look at the protests
scripting that country and how cubans
living here in las vegas are showing
their solidarity
you're watching politics now
recently protesters have been filling
the streets of cuba rallying against the
communist government there
the cuban protests have been triggered
by food shortages rising prices and the
government's response to
more covid19 infections well on tuesday
hundreds of people marched in solidarity
right here
in las vegas i think it's very important
for our voice to be heard
since we are such a big country the more
we go out
the better it is if cuba is on the
streets
we can be on the streets as well we need
everybody to open their eyes
because the reality is that
we're hurting a lot protesters are also
calling on the u.s government to
intervene
on monday president biden released a
statement saying the united states calls
on the cuban regime to hear their people
and serve their needs at this vital
moment
the homeland security secretary says the
u.s will not give any additional help
to folks fleeing cuba by boat in
washington the biden administration is
signing more people to work on the
backlog of daca applicants the dreamers
since the program reopened in december
there were more than 81
000 new applicants only 1900 have been
processed
another 13 thousand renewal requests are
waiting
senator cortez masto's been one of those
on capitol hill
pressing the administration to deal with
this backlog
senate democrats have unveiled a draft
bill to decriminalize marijuana
nationwide
it would remove pot from the federal
controlled substances list
give cannabis businesses access to
banking it regulates and taxes marijuana
sales and clears records for
non-violent marijuana crimes there is
some pushback but democratic leaders say
federal pot laws disproportionately hurt
minorities
in 2019 there were more marijuana
arrests
than all other violent crime arrests
combined
and the majority of those were for
simple possession it's invested in by
tobacco alcohol and pharma
the drug is much more potent and much
more addictive than it's ever
been talk about this alex limon from our
washington dc bureau alex
here in nevada we've had recreational
marijuana for four years
and a problem we've heard from the very
beginning banks won't work with them
so how does this help solve that well
that's right right now banks cannot work
with marijuana related businesses
because
marijuana is still illegal on a federal
level both sales
as well as possession but what this
proposal from the top
some of the top democrats in the senate
would do
is remove marijuana from the federal
controlled substances list
in essence decriminalizing it and taking
away
also a lot of the enforcement because it
would actually shift
the enforcement of marijuana related
matters from the drug enforcement agency
that handles it now to the food and drug
administration and so the idea
is that instead of criminalizing it
the the government could instead
regulate and even tax marijuana sales so
it would be a complete
game changer for those banks to be able
to work with dispensaries and grow
operations and other related businesses
what potentially would be sort of wiped
clean well so what the authors of this
bill
want is for anyone who has
low level non-violent marijuana related
convictions like simple possession to be
able to expunge their records
and also for people who are still
currently serving time to be able to
petition
to have their sentences reduced again
for those similar low-level
non-violent type of offenses all right
so what's the reaction on capitol hill
especially from republicans in
on the other side of the aisle any idea
that this isn't even a chance of passing
democrats would have to get 10
republicans along with every single
democrat in the u.s senate to agree to
this proposal in order to make it law
that's probably
going to be pretty difficult there are
obviously many conservative
republicans who feel that marijuana
should not be
decriminalized and some who even feel
that this bill
in essence legalizes it while it doesn't
force states to allow the sale of
recreational marijuana again you're
taking away that federal enforcement arm
so they say in essence it does legalize
it
however senator chuck schumer is trying
to remain positive he said that if
cities and states very conservative
states like south dakota
can in fact pass decriminalization laws
then he feels that it should be possible
on a federal level as well and he said
he's going to put his clout and his
weight as a majority leader
to try to get this initiative through
the senate
and that was alex limon reporting from
washington d.c
next on politics now trying for
diversity in pot ownership
we're going to talk about the meeting
that figures out rules for pot lounges
moving forward
this week in what to watch how will pot
lounges how will those licenses be
handed out moving forward
on monday there will be a meeting held
with a cannabis equity and inclusion
community to try and talk about it
one of the requirements is half of the
licenses would be handed out to
social equity applicants this meeting
will figure out
exactly what that means and who counts
as a social equity applicant of course
the pot lounges approved
in the last legislative session we'll
have that for you coming up next week as
well
also we're going to keep following the
changes with the coronavirus regulations
the state saying
that possibly folks should be wearing
masks even if you're vaccinated inside a
recommendation
we'll continue to follow those changes
as well moving forward with that we
thank you very much for watching
politics now for the latest in political
news
head to 8newsnow.com and we'll see you
right back here next saturday thanks for
watching
you